[Music]  i i never thought about it i just kept  working  and i worked at three different plants  which added up to about 67 years of  working on airplanes  with most windows of almost 50 years  here  in long beach on the c-17  like things physical i don't want to sit  in the office all day  i always got a job where i was moving  around  maybe that's why i'm 101.  my grandson took three hours of taking  pictures with me  with everybody i took pictures with  everybody so they said to john  aren't you grandma going to get tired he  said you don't know her do you  [Laughter]  [Music]  you make history in your own way with  the new  technology we have we have so much new  technology  and they've proven it already they're  proving it  oh my goodness the smart women we see i  just  adore all those girls there i was so  proud that there was  eight women only two men we made history  now it's your turn